hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm also Jerry
we're gonna be reviewing the video today
for Tekken 7 no hard the opening
cinematic trailer yeah from the still
and looking at it looks like we're
getting a peek and decided hell right
now
yeah no they they partnered with TJ or
token this day and so now you can do is
right now isn't it no Tekken love that
game we almost made a second short film
when we were like in seventh grade did
not go over well his mom got my meta my
dad it was just a horrible experience
yeah there was a lot of coordination
issues yeah but that's how much we love
Tekken that we were willing to try to
make the first film about it the Tekken
movie is not as good as what we could
have offered that live action when they
made in Korea yeah with a guy who played
Shang Tsung but they made him hate Hachi
what yeah that's a [ __ ] stupid they
are I remember watching the animated
movie that was a good one stir it was
like yeah hello violent and there's also
like a another Asian one but you and be
out what yeah yeah weird huh I know who
you and Bo is better than some of you
guys though
[Music]
so tools to to sugah man these two have
been fighting for like 18 years
Raja is a billionaire
want us it
down
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
shows how the characters look
for school
Wow [ __ ]
[Music]
an all-new direction
[Music]
oh you imagine oh goes to look like in
our cake I I hope that in the actual
gameplay you can [ __ ] do that
triangle laser thing and it'll probably
special meant that I'd be pretty sweet
after power ups order uh Tekken to me is
still the like I was at Dan's a while
ago playing Tekken that game is just the
best fighting game to me I do like in
more than Street Fighter what's really
cool about Tekken is they really honor
the fighting styles of whomever these
characters are you know and they all
their combos their moves that it's not
like the same buttons do the similar
things like they mix it up with the
combos like there's always like a
hundred different combos you could do
and it's always in tune with the
fighting style it's not like here's a
new power like you know here's a new
[ __ ] move from that fighting style
yeah so that's what's really cool about
it that was one of the things that kind
of was not as appealing to me in this
trailer because it seemed more about
like the powers you don't get a sense as
much for their style is just the fact
that they're hitting each other super
hard yeah exactly yeah these dudes hate
the [ __ ] out of each other and do
[ __ ] Kazuya and Heihachi have been
like going at it for like ever
wait does since it first Jin no that was
Kazuya Jin is is really a son well yeah
but I thought Jin was playing I know
that was that was definitely kazoo cuz
doesn't Jin turn into a demon ah yeah
that's right I'm not sure we regardless
even Ginny Miyaichi I go ahead this
entire family has been fighting each
other but yeah just because for really
looked I want to see the other character
I mean like you know cuz part of it I
know they've added and subtracted
characters over the years and I'm glad
to see the Jin Jin I thought you're not
letting this go yeah they're like it
looks like they're already dead and hell
yeah and they're still like we're gonna
sell this okay you can't get any deader
but they're still going to settle this
ever it was like I want to see her wrong
and I want to see ya eddy gordo and some
of the
their characters Yoshimitsu yoshimitsu
well they added like another didn't on
the last game did they add another like
strange creature type character cuz like
what is Yoshimitsu um Yoshimitsu is a
it's a type of position where the man
penetrates them no not the butthole and
then he slowly pulls out and then a
fountain of poop goes out like when a
boy is a statue in their urine but it's
a water floating you know this is the
worst description this is the most
upsetting description you have an ever
use for anything and it hurts my teeth
and Laila long because the lobby below
no label oolong is really based off
Jackie Chan's rules everybody waits a
minute do you tell me somebody else is
based off for law or martial law yeah or
martial law is the sama home Joe cool I
mean looks like Tekken they're still
fighting those two do with the Tekken
anything like are they fighting yeah I
can't help the other fist tournament has
involving yeah like I would love to see
a game played rather well a legit
gameplay trailer as cool as the
cinematics are what's cool about Tekken
world is there's a huge backstory to all
these characters that the game footage
doesn't necessarily provide you with but
you can like totally hook it all up and
realize like holy [ __ ] that's what that
footage means then you hear this whole
backstory I wish to cinematic clips
portray more of that yeah it's like I
get like at a certain point we are not
room this for fight scenes it's like we
know that we're gonna do a lot of
fighting but like it's not like an
in-depth character game but like you
know just like give me a cool character
moment or something what I feel like I'd
rather not watch a cinematic fight scene
because the whole thing is just fighting
so yeah I'm gonna do a lot of that yeah
this game I'd rather just see some story
now ya know or although still or do what
Mortal Kombat except that was what got
me most excited about the recent world
combat game was like that video they put
out where it was like different
characters fighting in different
locations
and a couple cool boobs it was like that
makes me want to play this game like
this trailer is like I want to play
Tekken just cuz it's Tekken yeah I don't
necessarily want to play it because I
saw this trailer yeah I feel that way
too
anyway guys thanks for telling us that
video is out if you needed the channel
you can subscribe to the Rio rejects you
can check out Jerry show reasons to
Jerry on this channel that's what it's
called check it out there's a button to
click it
link in description box and he'll do one
shadow Nicolas Reynoso yeah woo going to
California soon oh subscriber hit us up
phone yeah I would love to meet Oh buddy
I would love to have a shout-out from
you and an invite to be on the show
whoa you can totally come on the show
you [ __ ] although that's pretty
unrealistic we would be too sexy sons of
[ __ ] you're damn right would be too
sexy sons of [ __ ] let's see what you
[ __ ] look like since you want to come
on this channel sexy son [ __ ] of you
are sexy Saiman [ __ ] do you look like
[ __ ] Paul from Tekken but with black
hair what is it about fighting games
that like requires you to have one guy
with really tall hair and one guy who's
also got the head of an animal but dude
you do look sexy was the rest years
things say and I've been told I should
be a comedian
well this comment is [ __ ] hilarious
PS your girlfriend is so freaking
gorgeous does she poop rainbows she does
poop rainbows she farts flowers and she
pisses orchids which are also flowers
yeah I mean it's putting aside the fact
that that was really disturbing to hear
about I just like that that you did that
she farts solid things and yet she poops
rainbows and then she far as these
things that are not she had a really
unique digestive system yes I don't want
to hear any more but no Nicolas Reynoso
if you come you know what I know so I
know you be coming on this channel when
you come to California I don't know
where you're from but you are sexy and I
like your hair
and you look age-appropriate to come on
this channel if you're not 18 you might
have a problem I can't tell most of
these pictures roof
you look Armenian don't say thanks does
this profile somebody he does look
Armenian that's is that a no he's
probably married what he's Armenian
American American like unless you're a
Native American really really robbery
Armenian some of the hottest sheiks I've
ever seen are I know just don't assume
like it's on inside but like I know some
people don't take kindly just to
automatically being labeled a race to
[ __ ] do I care it's not like I'm gonna
hear him say something back to me you
might get try something backs
communicated with you over there now you
know I might type something back but you
know some won't be like but I don't have
to hear it out loud I don't that's my
point it doesn't affect me as much what
if every hater on this channel decided
to vocalize to me their hatred
that would bring me down who you would
get tired that'll be a long day but you
know when it's on a comment you're like
alright move enough don't have to keep
reading I'm kidding you're fair Armenian
it's Greek hey that wasn't